I gotta pee it's a problem wait what I
gotta pee it's a problem alright let's
unpack that come on this week's Keeping
Up with the Kardashians Kim is taking us
behind the scenes of her 2019 Met Gala
look apparently fashion and puddly
functions don't mix and it's a repeat
issue that was very hard to breathe in
and I'm not promoting not sitting and
not eating and not peeing and not moving
that was definitely a once-in-a-lifetime
situation I couldn't get my my metal one
out I just literally it was a slit and I
have to go like this and like almost be
on the floor but I want some granny's
stuff who is this man and why does he
want Kim Kardashian wearing a diaper
anyway the issue first came up and Kim's
get ready with me video with Vogue I
won't be able to clean you for about
four hours so we're coming up with a
plan of what we do in case of an
emergency and there's just no other
options I only saved my feed this whole
time you guys so of course I'm gonna
have to be like a million very often and
now we know what the plan was if it's an
emergency I think I keep my pants and
then have my sister white milega
which sister do you think had to be on
leg wiping duty it had to be either
Kendall or Kylie I'm guessing Kendall
billionaires don't do pee cleanups but
models maybe anyway Kim was basically
locked into her Met Gala look by Mugler
just look at all that course at work
okay so Anna
if I don't sit down for dinner now you
know why I'll be walking around mingling
talking but I cannot hardly say so
I can only like half sick and she also
had shapewear on underneath that I did
wear my solution wear underneath though
because I use it as as a lining so I had
the short on with the full corset on top
of that because the material of what the
dress was made out of it was like a
little bit itchy so I I use it sometimes
is just a lining whether I'm wearing
wool pants or something that I just
wouldn't be that comfortable in I use it
for so many different reasons yeah well
that would make it hard to pee that's
like three layers of I can't talk about
this anymore so I guess I'll leave it
right there
stick with ET for all the latest on Kim
Kardashian and I guess her bladder I'm
Katy Kraus and I'll see you next time